hey everybody I am Nick Gillespie with
reason and today is our reason live
stream and I'm going to bring our guests
into the show right now
uh uh as I was saying I'm Nicholas with
reason this is the reason live stream
for Thursday February 9th and I'm joined
by my reason colleague Jacob Solomon
senior editor Jacob please say hello
hello okay and uh we're also uh joined
by Heritage Foundation uh legal fellow
Amy swear who writes a lot about the
Second Amendment and defense of gun use
Amy thanks for joining us thank you so
much for having me so what we're going
to do today uh is talk about gun rights
and gun violence in Joe Biden's America
I'm not sure I suspect all three of us
would agree that uh you know it's not
really Joe Biden's America but uh you
know that's the convention and uh what I
want to start off with so we'll talk
about uh Biden's General attitude and
discussion of gun rights and second
amendment rights uh and then we're going
to uh talk about the state of gun
ownership in the country and the way
that it's been changing over the past 20
years or so so and then we're going to
talk about the state of gun violence in
America and what is the connection if
any between gun control legislation and
gun violence uh robust second amendment
rights uh and and you know whether or
not we're in a more peaceful Society or
not I want to start off by
um running uh two short clips of Joe
Biden uh the first is from last June uh
after uh the uh mass shooting in Buffalo
at a top Supermarket there so let's
listen to this and then I'm going to
play a clip from the state of the union
just earlier uh this year but let's
listen one message for all of us
do something just do something
for God's sake do something
after Columbine after Sandy Hook after
Charleston after Orlando after Las Vegas
after Parkland nothing has been done
this time that can't be true
this time we must actually do something
okay and now uh here he is talking in
the State of the Union
do something do something
that was The Plea of parents who lost
their children in Uvalde I met with
every one of them
do something about gun violence he saved
lives
it's time we do the same
band assault weapons now ban them now
once and for all
of that okay so uh Amy let me ask you
first you know Joe Biden in the wake of
uh you know a series of gun mass
shootings last year and then more
recently you know there were a couple of
events in January or earlier this year
and in the State of the Union you know
the the refrain of doing something uh
had seems to have a sense of urgency and
specifically when he's talking about
banning assault weapons what what's your
reaction to that kind of rhetoric well
the first immediate reaction that I have
is someone who works in public policy is
do something is never a good basis upon
which to to build public policy it
should never be just do something it
should be do the right thing within a
constitutional framework do an effective
thing uh and from a gun policy
perspective specifically
Banning so-called assault weapons is not
that effective thing I mean just look at
some of the shootings that he referenced
and so he he referenced uh the the
Chinese Lunar New Year shooting that
that unfortunately just happened in
California in January you mentioned
Columbine he mentioned Buffalo those all
involve time periods or locations in
which assault weapons were already
banned California has a more restrictive
assault weapons ban than the federal
government has ever imposed Columbine
occurred during the height of the
federal assault weapons ban uh Buffalo
is in New York which also has an assault
weapons ban
um so when you start with this General
premise of well just do something do
anything
it's not a good basis by which to do the
right thing or the helpful or effective
thing and you can see that here can you
uh very quickly you you mentioned
so-called assault weapons you know
assault weapon I think everybody pretty
much agrees as a term of art not of
science when Joe Biden and people who
are in favor of an assault weapons ban
are talking about assault weapons what
do they mean and why is that definition
not really up to the task sure so first
let's start with what an assault weapon
is not it is not a machine gun right it
is not a fully automatic firearm where
it you pulled the trigger and it will
just continuously fire bullets until you
stop right it's not one of those it is a
semi-automatic firearm which is the same
as essentially every type of firearm
that has been created in modern times
it's the most common type it means you
pull the trigger once it fires one round
so you have to continually pull that
trigger now the difference between an
assault been in a so so-called not
assault weapon
is certain types of features so it's
generally defined as a semi-automatic
typically rifle that has one two or or
more of the following cosmetic features
something like a pistol grip something
like a barrel shroud or a collapsing or
folding stock so it's nothing related to
caliber so sometimes people think that
banning assault weapons means Banning a
specific type of ultra deadly caliber a
firearm it it doesn't it doesn't affect
the size of the gun or the muzzle
velocity or anything remotely related to
to deadliness or lethality
it's really comes down to almost the the
Comfort
um you know the the ability of a person
to hold it in a more comfortable fashion
um but it doesn't affect rate of fire
um or anything of that nature so it's
essentially the same gun but one looks
scarier than the other right and it can
be sort of configured especially for
novice Shooters to to shoot more
comfortably
uh Jacob you were writing about assault
weapons for reason back when the federal
assault weapon ban was was in force
um what happened the last time that um
you know there was an assault uh weapon
ban in place
uh well I think it's worth pointing out
that Biden himself
has conceded the point that Amy was
making which is that under that ban
manufacturers could make slight mostly
cosmetic changes to their weapons and
they could sell firearms that were in
Biden's words just as deadly so given
that it is extremely implausible to
think that uh drawing these distinctions
would have any kind of measurable impact
on either mass shootings or gun violence
in general
uh what he doesn't understand or perhaps
understands what doesn't concede is that
the new version of the federal ban
that's been proposed has exactly the
same problem so now it's one feature
that disqualifies a gun versus two
features the features are slightly
different but the fact remains that if
you remove a barrel shroud or if you you
replace an adjustable stock with a fixed
stock these changes do not affect the
fundamental function of the weapon it
buys the same ammunition at the same
rate the same muzzle velocity
so it's completely inconsistent for him
to concede on the one hand that the band
that expired in 2004 uh had no
meaningful impact on the on The
lethality of Legally available weapons
and then to say in the same breadth that
we're going to have this new improved
one that overcomes that problem but it
doesn't it's it's inherent in the nature
of these laws that they draw
distinctions that have little practical
significance especially when you're
talking about a mass shooting do you
what's the etymology of assault weapon
you know because this again if you go
back to the 90s this was a major you
know focus of debate and and a federal
legislation but
um when did people start talking about
assault weapons as opposed to automatic
versus semi-automatic or you know
whatever caliber and things like that
Jacob well that that question's a bit
controversial because gun control people
will tell you this was an industry term
and there are examples of early examples
of Industry using uh that term but
there's no question that it was
popularized by gun control activists and
who explicitly said we are capitalizing
on the Public's confusion about the
distinction between machine guns and
semi-automatic weapons and machine guns
have been banned since the 30s right
well they're effectively they've been uh
strictly regulated I mean since 1986 you
can't a civilian cannot buy a newly
manufactured machine gun the ones that
are owned now are registered with the
government you have to pay a tax they
don't care much in crime
and uh the the uh the weapons that are
are covered by uh these saw weapon Bans
are not not machine guns as Amy Amy
mentioned
um so
just at at this you know preliminary
level it's just there's no reason to
think that this would have a meaningful
impact Biden claims that during the
uh when the ban was in fact from 94 to
2004 uh there was a reduction either in
uh fatalities or in incidents of mass
shootings
um it's controversial as to exactly what
that reduction was but it is on its face
impossible to to attribute uh you know
what happened then to Simply to the
assault weapon why why is that well if
you look at the the figures for uh mass
shootings and I'm going to hear mostly
talk about public past shootings which
is what Biden is referring to and these
are traditionally defined as
shootings in public that kill at least
four people besides the the assailants
these numbers are highly volatile
looking back in the last decade and a
half or so they're generally in the
single digits and all all but one year
they were in the single digits one year
had 10 of them yeah and right now and
I'm sorry to interrupt but right now I'm
just uh keep talking but in the
background what people will see is a
animated story uh kind of illustration
of mass shootings in the United States
yeah you can get much higher figures if
you expand the definition and you often
see people claiming you know hundreds of
mass shootings in a given Year and that
comes from expanding the definition to
include cases with fewer fatalities
perhaps no fatalities cases in different
uh crimes that are committed in in
private settings that involve gangs and
this sort of thing but if what we're
talking about is the thing that strikes
fear Into the Heart of Americans which
is the idea that you're out in a public
place and some some Maniac is going to
come in there and shoot it up and
possibly kill you these remain in very
rare events in the past few years
there has been
you know something of an increase in
both incidents and fatalities
in 2020 even as murders Rose over all
the number of Mass public shootings went
down I mean again we're talking about
maybe from eight to four that's a big
percentage change but we're still
talking about very small numbers
since then you know after 2020 they went
up again in percentage terms pretty
dramatically but that's maybe a
reversion to the norm
um it's very hard to draw any kind of
conclusions about these Trends because
there are uh they're driven by you know
for example uh there was a year 2017
where you had a very high number and
usually High number of fatalities for
mass shootings which was mostly
attributable to events the attack in Las
Vegas and the attack at the church in uh
Sutherland Springs Texas
these sort of you know random events
will skew these figures
um and uh so it's very hard to draw any
firm conclusions about what's going on
in terms of Trends even more so to
attribute any changes to a particular
law
um yeah well I was going to say though
you know particularly for me the uh you
know and I and I I speak as you know a
hardcore libertarian who believes in the
Second Amendment I am not particularly
interested in gun issues I'm convinced
that the rate of gun ownership and the
rate of gun violence seemed to be
Loosely correlated at fast and possibly
positively correlated in the sense of
more guns there are in circulation the
less violent crime there seems to be
committed by guns or with guns but
um having said that you know something
like the Las Vegas shooting is
absolutely terrifying right where you
are you know and that to not only the
the particulars of it where it's just a
bunch of people in an open-air concert
suddenly being shot to death from you
know a hotel room and things like that
but there's to my understanding there's
been no clear explanation of like the
motivation of the shooter or anything
like that um right and that's that's why
this this scares people because it is
unpredictable uh it's the motivations
are are often inscrutable yeah or just
plain Insanity I mean where it's like
you know well and the difficulty the
fundamental difficulty with trying to
prevent these kinds of crimes is that
nobody can predict reliably predict who
will commit a crime like this I know
we'd like to think otherwise we'd talk
about red flags uh but but even you know
mental health professionals are terrible
at predicting whether it's a person will
actually uh you know commit a crime of
violence
um given that it is implausible to think
that legislators or police officers who
you know for example who file red flag
petitions are going to be good at
distinguishing between all of the you
know weird
anti-social people in America
who who shows certain signs that may in
some cases look quite disturbing
um and the ones who actually will commit
crimes like these because this is a very
very small share of all the weird uh
disgruntled people
um and so that's a very hard problem to
crack and what happens is you end up
casting a wider net in the hope that
you're going to catch the people who
actually are bent on mass murder but
then you sweep in lots of people who
actually are harmless
and in the case of red flag laws uh they
lose their second amendment rights for a
year or more
as a result of of concerns raised by
other people
which may may or may not be well
grounded and may or may not be honest
some in some cases you get malicious
petitions by people with an axocrine so
that's a serious problem that that
requires at the very least uh
good due process protections and let's
let's talk about red flag loss more
specifically in in a second but Amy uh
you know Joe Biden talks about being the
most uh uh you know kind of the most
effective president on gun legislation
in recent memory last year uh Congress
passed and he signed readily and he
supported and endorsed and pushed Along
gun control legislation that you know is
legitimately considered the biggest gun
control federal gun control legislation
in decades can you summarize what was in
that and you know what are what are we
seeing as a result of that
sure so you know
I think a lot of people have gotten this
package because it's really a package of
of gun related laws wrong I um on the
one hand yes it is I think the most
significant step toward gun control that
that has happened from at least a
legislative standpoint I'd argue there
have been some some agency changes with
with the ATF that have have been equally
as significant
um but certainly in terms of legislation
uh in summary there's a lot of
additional spending tied to mental
health
um and school safety which is not on the
whole a bad idea um you know it's it's
always only going to be as good as as it
is implemented effectively and you can
always argue about you know should that
be coming from the federal government or
is this something for states to figure
out but the the big things that came out
of this were so-called expanded
background checks for 18 to 21 year olds
um which it's very unclear what that
exactly means uh even within the text of
the language itself it seems to suggest
that
um the these 18 to 21 year olds who are
otherwise law abiding citizens could uh
in theory be subject to like longer
essentially waiting periods that that
don't apply to other young adults there
was some language in there about uh
domestic violence misdemeanors but again
very very vague as to what that actually
means and whether it actually expanded
existing categories
um you know some funding potentially of
red flag laws but also again of other
like mental health courts and things of
that nature so on the whole it was steps
toward gun control but there was really
nothing
in their you know I think gun control
Advocates have actually taken a Victory
lap that they they didn't really get
there um you know there was not an
assault weapons ban or a magazine
capacity ban or anything of that nature
um you know and I I may be forgetting
one or two aspects of of that overall
package so it wasn't great
um it it certainly didn't clarify
anything but it wasn't this you know
devastating step toward gun control that
where this Victory lap is being taken
either do you worry about Joe Biden you
know he you know and the State of the
Union Address just a couple days ago he
said do something we need to do
something we haven't done enough and he
says you know ban assault weapons once
and for all do you worry is is he uh you
know in the parlance of gun control uh
opponents or or gun rights activists is
he a gun grabber yeah I think the the
rhetoric the way in which he talks is
certainly concerning you know he can
call himself the most effective gun
control president I I think by by far he
is the most vocal and I think the most
flippant in terms of of how he both
mischaracterizes a lot of the issues
um you know the the quips about you know
what are you trying to hunt deer in
Kevlar vests or
um sort of phrasing things in a way that
would suggest well of course you should
give up your guns because if you don't
we have f-16s and I'll just send in the
military to do it anyway
um you know so he's been very flippant
in a way that that past presidents uh
have not been even when advocating for
the same laws and I think that more than
anything should be concerning to the
American people Jacob uh very quickly
what's wrong with a waiting period
um for you know you apply for a gun uh
you know whether it's a a handgun or a
rifle
uh you know this is something that's you
know you know potentially incredibly
dangerous uh you know what's wrong with
uh you know a background check and uh
and a waiting period for that well the I
mean the waiting period is not at the
federal level there's not a waiting
period strictly speaking you have to
pass a background check and it's just
that it takes a bit the background check
has to be limited yeah and and uh you
know I think the Democrats would like to
make make the amount of time allowed uh
long
um and uh you know in some states do
have waiting periods per se and the
problem with that is that people who are
in danger and want to arm themselves for
self-protection you know that can be a
really uh crucial obstacle and it can
endanger people's lives if it's somebody
you know a woman who's threatened by you
know a former boyfriend or an ex-husband
for example it may be urgent for her to
to have a gun for self-defense but in
terms of the the the background checks
this is an approach that the law we were
talking about the bipartisan safer
communities act
doubled down on and and
neither Democrats nor Republicans to
question the current system and they
really should because under federal law
currently
you have wide categories of Americans
who have no second amendment rights for
dubious reasons for example uh people uh
people who use marijuana
even in the in states where it's legal
are not allowed to own guns under
federal law people who have ever been
subjected to involuntary psychiatric
psychiatric treatment even if it's for
suicidal impulses for example and they
were never deemed a threat to others
they lose their right uh to Armed
self-defense forever
people with felony convictions even if
it the crimes didn't involve violence
even if they didn't involve victims even
you know if it's a drug offense you lose
your right to own guns forever now this
law
I said that's fine but we need to
increase the penalties for violating
these rules so they raise the maximum
penalty for illegal possession uh from
10 years to 15 years they created a new
crime which they called trafficking and
Firearms which is not trafficking in
firearms because it includes uh you know
if you're a marijuana user or somebody
with with a a drug felony record and you
try to buy a gun that qualifies as
trafficking Firearms that's another 15
years maximum penalty so it seems
completely insane in practice uh you
know they're not sending marijuana users
to prison for 15 years because they own
a gun right but it can happen that's
what the law says and this is a live
issue right now because there are cases
uh challenging in particular the ban on
gun ownership by marijuana users there
was a case in Florida that was actually
brought by the Secretary of I think it's
agriculture culture and consumer affairs
there where she said look uh I want to
protect medical marijuana users in
Florida it's not right that they lose
their second amendment rights because
they're participating in this program so
the judge in that case dismissed the
lawsuit
uh the Biden Administration uh you know
they defended uh the ban saying uh we
think this is Justified we think it's
constitutional a judge agreed but in
Oklahoma recently another federal judge
in another case said this is blatantly
unconstitutional this is not consistent
with the way the right to arm self armed
self-defense has been historically
understood with the kinds of regulations
that were thought to be consistent with
that right right
um and it is very hard to come up with
historical analogs that uh look like
that sort of rule uh where an entire
category of people based on substances
they consume
um uh are not allowed to have guns in
any context
um uh so if you're looking for a closed
analogy you won't find one the best they
can find is examples of laws from the
19th century or earlier where people who
were actively intoxicated were either
not allowed not supposed to carry guns
around not supposed to fire guns right
but this you know this band when it
comes to unlawful users of Controlled
Substances goes much further than that
it says if you use any of these drugs
you know Congress
um you may not have a gun for any
purpose in any context uh so that's
going to be a live issue is that when it
gets up to the Supreme Court it's not
clear what they're going to say I mean
historically you would think that since
they tend to cater to anti-drug
prejudices that they would say this is
fine but if they are following through
in the approach that they set forth in
their decision last June uh you have to
demonstrate that this uh there is a
historic Circle tradition uh that
justifies this and that's just very hard
to do yeah let's talk about that Amy uh
you know just a couple of days with uh
before Biden signed legislation that the
gun legislation last year the Supreme
Court ruled that a New York state ban on
uh the ability of people to carry
weapons was unconstitutional and it
seems like you know certainly for the
past 20 years or so every time that a
gun case has come up the Supreme Court
has expanded the right uh to own or
carry guns something similar at least
going back to the 90s has been happening
broadly at the state level where it is
easier now for more people to own and
carry weapons in a variety of
circumstances what is going on that you
know legislation or at least you know
within uh the uh Biden Administration
and the Democratic party at the national
level and it's in certain State houses
are moving towards more gun control but
it seems like the legal arguments are
all kind of in favor of more a more
robust defense of second amendment
rights yeah well I would actually push
back on that characterization a little
bit of the Supreme Court you know
expanding rights I I think really the
the better characterization historically
is to say that the Supreme Court sat
around on its hands declining to to
intervene but then for decades as States
um you know interrupted and rewrote
essentially the Second Amendment to to
mean yeah no we can infringe this right
however we want
um you know up to it including like DT
completely Banning the possession of
handguns
um so from that respect you know for
many of us in in our lifetimes it's
certainly this new feeling of of seeing
the Supreme Court intervene in that way
um but I think a lot of these laws uh
that we've sort of established in the
last couple of decades going back to the
60s I think a good number of them are up
for very serious challenge if Bruin is
applied uh honestly
um you know things not not just like you
know we talked about um bans on uh felon
ownership of firearms for for people
like Martha Stewart for non-violent
felons but things like the federal ban
on the the purchase of handguns for
individuals under the age of of 21 which
would include even more restrictive
state laws for individuals
um 18 to 21 who are entirely barred from
their second amendment rights
um you're seeing in what has it been now
eight months since Bruin a range of
legislation being challenged and shot
down and I think you're right what's
interesting is that at the same time
you're seeing States like Oregon for
example moving a completely restrictive
Direction so it's setting up this
conflict though I do want to asterisk
that a little bit because on the one
hand you have States like not just
Oregon but also California New Jersey in
response to Bruin moving in a more
restrictive Direction
at the same time you you've also seen
what I think is actually a bigger
majority or at least a plurality of
States moving in a less restrictive
Direction with respect to public carry
um so we've we've now actually reached a
point where I think it's 25 states by
last count do not require a permit
anymore to carry guns for self-defense
in public as long as you're not
otherwise prohibited from possessing
firearms so the movement's really been
all over the place you know you've had
some states moving to more permissive
care you've had other states trying to
to crack down on it even more so and now
you have this component of of Bruin
which would seem to to put at risk a lot
of these gun control laws in a way that
I I think is is
get again setting up those battles over
the next couple of years Jacob uh real
quickly then I want to talk about the
state of gun ownership because it's you
know it that's a fascinating question
it's also a difficult reality to fully
you know grasp
um for you know uh for all kinds of uh
just practical reasons but do you worry
Jacob that
um you know that
um gun control or gun laws and gun
issues are becoming part of a broader
set of culture War issues you know and
it's funny Amy or or uh yeah Amy
mentioned Oregon you know on the one
hand Oregon is setting all kinds of uh
you know the pace in terms of legalizing
and decriminalizing all sorts of drug
laws and opening things up and then on
the other hand they're like you know
they're they're clamping down on gun gun
ownership or gun rights and things like
that and are you worried at all Jacob
that gun rights and the Second Amendment
is becoming firmly enmeshed in a kind of
where if you're on the right if if
you're on the right or you're part of
the right wing you are pro-second
Amendment whatever that means and if
you're on the left you're against it
yeah I'm actually I'm working on a book
right now about uh the parallels between
uh gun control and Drug control and
they're very striking divides uh between
the parties and and based on ideology
where people are are in the political
Spectrum progressives tend to be very
critical of the war on drugs and they
know all sorts of problems that it
creates they know that it was racist and
it's an Inception that it used to have a
disproportionate impact on on uh blacks
and uh uh other minority groups that uh
it you know undermines civil liberties
that it uh contributes to corruption all
you know this whole Litany of problems
but if you look at gun control uh you
can say very similar things about its
history its current consequences the
racially uh disparate impact
um and undermining civil liberties
inviting police abuse all that sort of
thing and it's like conservatives can
see those problems when it comes to gun
control but they generally don't see
them when it comes to drug control and
the the reverse is true for people on
the left so it's it is unfortunate
because really for for to a large degree
they're complaining about the same
problems what happens when the
government says you may not own these
things
and we're going to make sure that that
you can't get them
um uh it invites all sorts of abuses
only everyone could be libertarian right
the elegant pollution yes yes but but it
really is uh I mean I I do that is that
really does concern me because in
principle both sides the progressives
and conservatives should be able to see
that the other side is making valid
points
um but they tend not to because they see
those other people as their enemy right
um and therefore automatically dismiss
what they have to say it all comes back
to that Star Trek episode with Frank
gorshin where you know the one side one
group of people are white on one side
and black on the other and the other are
black on this side of white on that and
they hate each other and it takes
Captain Kirk the full hour to figure out
that they're actually different
uh also I just I wanted to add in terms
of the Fallout from Bruin the most
immediate uh the the closest cases are
the situations in States like uh New
York and New Jersey where they said okay
we're going to start granting Carry
Permits but you can't really use them
because we're going to say you can't you
know there's a a very long list of
places where you're not allowed to have
done congratulations you have the permit
but it's now worthless yeah so that
that's the most obvious case where this
is going to go up at the Supreme Court
and they're going to presumably it will
say cut that out right we met what we
meant what you what we said are there
are there any get around it by uh coming
up with these new restrictions to
replace the old restrictions you
actually have to let law-abiding people
exercise the right to bear arms
on the Supreme Court or are there any of
the liberal justices who are you know
good friendly towards second amendment
rights or or constitutional universe
restrictions on state power you know
I have a
as far as I can remember in the major
cases like Heller and McDonald and and
Bruin it's it's been a hard no from them
um so I I would not anticipate that
changing with respect to these major
fundamental questions about the scope of
the Second Amendment
um I I do want to put a little bit of an
addendum on what Jacob said though about
um gun ownership recently I think it is
important to note that well that the
general trend is is still there with
respect to the The Divide between
parties
when you look at the the changing uh in
sort of Shifting grounds of gun
ownership especially since 2020. uh it
seems to be changing a little bit
um at least to the extent that one of
the fastest growing populations of both
concealed carry permit holders and
first-time gun owners is black women in
particular but also just sort of
Shifting toward minority gun ownership
and and growths vary I think that is
very important and it's important not
just for the the state of
um yeah you know the individual defense
but I think it's important for the state
of Second Amendment defense
philosophically I think it's a good
thing that that more and more Americans
of different demographic backgrounds are
recognizing for the first time oh I am
part of the people to whom this right
belongs I think that's a very very good
thing and I I hope that Trend continues
in in that direction yeah let's talk
about gun ownership and kind of the
demographics and the large numbers
um Jacob in the past and reason has
published stories about uh you know the
intended uh targets of gun control and
you know if I mean if there's a a
broad-based federal or state level
policy that is more discriminatory than
the drug war it's it's gun ownership
right or it's gun control legislation uh
which was always targeted at freed
blacks or you know newly freed blacks
and things like that here's a chart from
the Christian Science monitor that is
just talking about
the surgeon gun sales since the pandemic
and you know and if we're being uh you
know clear about things about the both
the uh the police killing of George
Floyd and and the um riots and uh and
demonstrations that followed in that you
can see down here uh new gun owners uh
between 2019 and 2021 one blacks make up
21 prior to that before 2019 they made
up about 10 percent
um Hispanics also saw a big increase
um gun ownership surged a bit in that
let me see if I can get back to this
slide right now
uh I'm sorry I'm not that facile with
this but according to Gallup in 2020
about 30 it looks like 32 percent Earth
let's say a third of Americans said they
owned a gun uh 41 44 lived in a
household With A Gun Jacob how have
those numbers changed over the past 20
or 30 years it's my understanding that
you know if you go back to the mid 90s
it was closer to like half of people
lived in a household with a gun or it
seems like there are more guns in
circulation but they are concentrated in
relatively fewer households is that
accurate and if so does that have any
implications either therefore you know
gun culture or gun control laws
yeah I mean that's basically right uh
the numbers in terms of prevalence of
adults ownership have have gone down
it's about a third a third according to
several surveys a third of adults who
own guns and again it is fat you know
this is a Bugaboo of mine it is you know
when you try to ascertain with any kind
of real accuracy basic facts about
everyday American life it's really hard
so it's all of this stuff is based on
surveys and things like that but yeah I
mean there was there was a recent survey
which is the largest ever conducted and
they they put uh the prevalence of gun
ownership among adults at about a third
and that's consistent with with other
surveys so it's probably more or less
right right
um and but as you noted the number of
guns in circulation I mean there are
hundreds of millions of guns in
circulation
um has increased all this time
um even even during this dramatic drop
uh in violent crime and and in gun crime
uh you know since the the 90s right in
the early 90s uh you get more and more
guns in circulation but somehow you get
less less and less uh violence and fewer
murders so that on the face of it does
not suggest that more guns necessarily
means more crime right in terms of the
demographics of gun ownership that I
think those numbers you know since uh
2020 or so are are encouraging
um I mean there there are uh there is
the sense that um in the black community
that at least among some people that
that we are we're covering a tradition
of armed self-defense uh that goes you
know back to slavery and then
emancipation and the Civil Rights
Movement
um having a gun was vitally important to
protect yourself against racist violence
especially when the government was not
either not doing anything about it or
actually producing or they were yeah
yeah they were the main um and and this
this uh this turnaround on on gun
control didn't really happen until the
60s up until then you had mainstream
black leaders including Martin Luther
King talking about about the you know
the ethics of of uh armed self-defense
uh they the I mean these people had guns
and they needed them
um and so that tradition has sort of
been lost uh now that sort of the
mainstream uh African-American
organizations now uh uniformly approve
of gun control they've joined that sort
of progressive Coalition that supports
these restrictions without paying much
attention
to who gets screwed over by these laws
and it's uh you know that you look at
the numbers in terms of who gets
arrested who gets prosecuted for illegal
gun possession this is one of the
arguments that that people made uh
before The Supreme Court's ruling and
Bruin uh that these laws that basically
make it impossible for you to have guns
uh for self-defense especially in places
where you'd want them right in high
crime neighborhoods
um in in big cities that they
disproportionately
um hurts black people
um and uh you know I don't know that
that was the main argument that was
persuasive to the stream report but it's
undeniably true uh so so you have to
start
questioning the impact of policies like
that and things like if you stop and
frisk programs which uh overwhelmingly
affect uh uh people minority groups
where they're looking for guns that's
what I mean at least ostensibly that's
what they're doing but of course it
leads to all sorts of abuses because
and they get patted down supposedly for
weapons but that's an outgrowth of these
policies that unfortunately uh you know
most of the the mainstream at least
African-American organizations support
those policies even though they have a a
really bad effect on their communities
do you think uh you know uh and
obviously you're you're thinking a lot
about the parallels between drug control
and gun control
um similar to the way that uh many black
leaders and black Civic groups were were
real drug warriors uh in the 80s and the
90s because it was their neighborhoods
and their constituents and communities
that seem to be taking it on the chin
the violence that accrued to black
market drug sales
um you know they ultimately you know
people like Charles Rangel who was one
of the you know uh main uh supporters of
harsh disparities between powder and
crack cocaine and then was like wow I
up I was wrong do you think that
that will happen with black black
Community groups and and Civic
associations well they come around on
gun control similar to the way that they
seem to have in a pretty big way on on
drug laws yeah I mean that that
president is encouraging uh because
you're right the I mean black members of
Congress were all in favor of these
really harsh uh drug penalties in
particular for crack cocaine but pretty
quickly they saw what happened that it
was disproportionately uh black people
who were who were uh suffering as a
result of this insane distinction where
which imposed you know more severe
penalties on people depending upon
whether the cocaine they had with smoke
with smoked or snorted
um they came around you know much more
quickly than than Joe Biden did for sure
yeah um so that that's I find that
somewhat encouraging and of course you
have a lot of objections to things like
stop and frisk right
um uh from which was always like they're
looking for guns or drugs right I mean
that's right so
that you definitely have you know uh uh
the NAACP and other organizations
objecting to programs like that but of
course the root cause and the rationale
for those tactics is we have to get guns
off the street right so so it doesn't
seem like a leap to say why do we have
these laws to begin with that make it so
hard to have guns for self-defense
um and is this a a sensible way to try
to reduce gun violence I mean you have
Progressive
um district attorneys in some cities
saying we need to distinguish between
somebody who is a dangerous criminal and
has guns for that reason and somebody
who's afraid of the dangerous criminals
and has guns even though it may be
illegal for them to possess them they
have guns because they're trying to
protect themselves and we shouldn't be
uh trying you know coming down hard on
the people who illegally possess guns
for self-defense we should be trying to
go after the the people who actually are
a threat to Public Safety and so that's
that's encouraging and and maybe that
will that will catch on in the future
yeah uh Amy talk a little bit about the
demographics of gun ownership in terms
of gender
um are women uh you know women are I
think only about 20 percent of the gun
owning population but also
geographically you know one of the
things I grew up in I was born in
Brooklyn I grew up in New Jersey New
Jersey does not have a robust gun
culture
um I did not grow up in a household my
father had fought in World War II and
you know was anti-gun after that you
know kind of I think somewhat
understandably but I've lived all over
the country and I was always amazed when
I moved to uh the Midwest and even
Western New York everybody had a gun
everybody grew up with a gun so you know
what what's going on with the
demographics in terms of female
ownership and then what are is there a
big Regional uh divide uh among
attitudes towards gun ownership in
America
yeah well certainly when when you look
at sort of the demographics
traditionally of gun ownership it's it's
predominantly male
um and it's predominantly at least
historically been you know more centered
in rural areas especially when compared
to urban areas
um now some of that sort of urban rural
divide I think can actually be
attributed to you know you can call it
gun culture but some of that gun culture
is either fostered or stifled by
restrictive gun laws it turns out if you
make it very inconvenient and burdensome
and put all of this administrative red
tape between people and their ability to
to keep and bear arms they're less
likely to develop that gun culture and
so I think that's part of it as well
uh in terms of women you know again we
talked about black women in particular
um over the last two three years
becoming one of the fastest growing
segments of new gun owners I think
you're seeing a shift generally amongst
women it's still pretty
disproportionately male but I think
you're seeing more and more women
um take on it and again understand the
importance
of that armed defense
um that that importance of of Death at a
distance if you will be being able to to
take on a bigger stronger a Salient
um you know in a more advantageous
position right uh I think that's
becoming an increasingly important uh at
least to a certain segment of women
um and I I hope that continues you know
again women are part of the people to
whom the right belongs uh it's it's
their right just as much as as men
um and and very quickly I want to Circle
back to something else Jacob had had
mentioned
um you know he he was talking about how
minorities are disproportionately
impacted uh in terms of of criminal gun
laws they're the ones disproportionately
finding themselves you know being
prosecuted for these crimes and he
mentioned just a little bit and I I
really want to bring this back up there
are also victimized by these gun laws in
the sense of they are disproportionately
likely to be victims of violent crime
and so when you disproportionately
impact them in that way and take away
their ability to defend themselves
they are infinitely uh more
disadvantaged in in when those gun rates
are taken away you see this very clearly
I think in a place like DC where you
know if you imagine DC it's like a wonky
try diamond shape right and you can
actually take a map of of demographics
and poverty levels and overlay it with
crime levels crime victimization levels
um and it's almost a one-to-one ratio
and what's very unfortunate is if you've
ever tried to get a gun in DC or
especially a carry permit in DC I think
it took me like nine months you know
hundreds of dollars you have to take
several days off work because there's no
public gun ranges in DC
um you know so if you have to take
public transportation or if you work
weekends
um you know or you know six seven
hundred dollars is just not something
you can come up with pretty easily
you are far less likely to be able to
defend yourself and again it's all
concentrated disproportionately against
certain demographics and certain
segments of society and I think it's
important that we recognize that as well
it's not just you know who ends up in
jail more often it's who ends up less
likely to defend themselves
despite the fact that they're more
likely to have to be in a position where
they have to defend themselves um we're
gonna start talking about the the press
the prevalence of violence in America
and the and a kind of return to a more
uh to a higher violent crime rate or at
least apparently over the past few years
from historic highs in the 90s but I
just want to run through a couple of uh
uh viewer questions or comments Lethal
Weapon asks where the calls to ban
assault knives assault cars assault bats
it's not the guns that kill people
people kill people my guns haven't
killed anyone on their own okay so uh
there's that JCS how can the government
uh
how can the government have so much
power denying rights if the founders
created checks and balances to prevent
this is it because lawyers know how to
circumvent the Constitution and
amendments I would say uh you know
certainly uh Congress does and lawmakers
in general uh and AF uh says isn't
removing people's access to guns for
getting mental help going to make them
less likely to use any resources to get
help sounds like stigmatizing extra
steps that's those are all interesting
comments let's go back to uh let's let's
talk about the prevalence of violence in
America
um right now here's a uh uh diagram or a
graph of the U.S murder rate in 1960 to
um obviously there were uh there there
are former Peaks where nowhere near
where we used to be but when we look at
things like annual murder rates in the
United States
um they're they're cropping up again uh
Jacob how does how does the recent rise
in violent crime impact the gun rights
debate do you think
well I mean I I should note that that
the recent upward Trend seems to be
going that it seems to be going down
again as of as of last year although
we're going to need you know more years
of data to see what's actually going on
um I mean you tend to think you would
tend to think that when uh violent crime
is more common there would be more more
support for gun control
but the problem is that people don't
really understand uh what's going on in
terms of crime rates I mean if you ask
the general public at any given time you
know what's the risk of being murdered
they tend to to greatly exaggerate it
and they tend to think that things are
worse than they've ever been even even
during periods when violent crime is is
declining precipitously
um and they so I don't think the public
has a good sense of the risks that
people face from violent crime to day
versus yesterday
um whether they're going up or down
um so I'm not sure there is a good
connection in there between
um or there's a strong connection there
between sentiment in favor of gun
control and and uh the current crime
rate because people generally don't
understand what the current crime rate
is right or which direction and I think
we can we can openly or you know
accurately say that uh Donald Trump in
particular when he was running in 2016
really foregrounded the issue of violent
crime in a way that had been missing
from National politics in a serious way
since the 90s uh you know and certainly
people like Bill Clinton and Hillary
Clinton when she uh was emerging as a
senator talked a lot about Super
Predators uh and you know a very kind of
uh apocalyptic rhetoric about
criminality that that was receding even
as it was being discussed so much
um but uh Amy what you know does the you
know are you worried about an increase
in violent crime and does that you know
does that lead people to be like we
should disarm more people in society or
it's like no let's let everybody let's
you know kind of devolve law enforcement
to the individual and I'm going to buy a
gun yeah well what I think is very
interesting about this this recent sort
of spike in in homicides and other
violent crimes that started around
mid-2020 very sudden spike is that it
coincided with a spike in in gun
purchases and and specifically
first-time gun ownership
um Rose exponentially I think something
like 10 or 12 million first-time gun
owners over the last two years and part
of that was you know regardless of how
sound the logic is
that Spike also coincided with
I think what a lot of people's
experience for potentially the first
times in their lives this this feeling
of the government isn't going to be
there right we're in the middle of covet
we're seeing sort of widespread civil
unrest
um this sort of feeling that wow okay if
I call 9-1-1 they might not show up in
time
um but on a broad scale and to see the
Confluence of all of that you know I I
don't think we have a clear picture
yet but it does seem that at least to
some extent it sort of tampers down this
it sort of bent toward gun control right
because you just had the nation
experience shoot uh if we you know gun
control sort of inherently implies that
we're trusting the government with our
right to self-defense
um and when you don't have that trust I
I think you're more likely to to not
have that impulse toward gun control now
obviously we're still seeing it
um from both the the president and your
traditional gun control groups that call
is not going to go away I just don't
know that this is necessarily the
inflection point where it's going to be
you know Ultra successful in a way that
it would not have been six or seven
years ago
um yeah for a long time Jacob uh you
know and this was certainly the case
under uh when Barack Obama was President
uh gun rights groups and particularly
the NRA and I kind of want to talk about
them as an institution uh in a second
but there you know a lot of people
bought a lot of guns and there was a lot
of rhetoric that Barack Obama was coming
for your guns you know he made that
comment about
um you know uh bitter klingers uh you
know who who cling to their gods and
their Guns Etc
um but nothing really happened there
seemed to be for a long time you know
gun control uh or debates was kind of
like abortion where both sides talked a
lot about it but there wasn't really
much being done
um do you think that's you know do you
think that's over now and is you know
are you know in the same way that
abortion is now you know a a real live
political issue at the state level
conceivably at the federal level is that
you you know are we in for you know a
decade-long kind of legislative court
public relations fight over over gun
laws in a way that we really aren't that
um uh that used to
well I mean for sure we're going to see
uh fights in the courts because uh
they're trying to figure out the
implications of Bruin and and you know
after that decision the Supreme Court
vacated Ford uh Decisions by appeals
courts where they upheld either assault
weapon bans or uh restrictions on
magazine capacity and the court didn't
say that was wrong it said reconsider
those decisions in light of what we said
in Bruin and just well in both cases uh
you know the court has said that the
test of whether uh arms are covered by
the Second Amendment is is whether
they're in common use for lawful
purposes and there's no question that
so-called assault weapons and so-called
large capacity magazines are in common
used for lawful purposes right so so now
you've gotten past that test and the
next question is is there some kind of
uh historical tradition of banning
arms like these yeah right
um and that's and the answer it's not
clear what what the Court's going to say
about that
um different judges are arriving at
different conclusions so you're
definitely going to see that you're
you're certainly going to see I don't
know if you're going to see you know
more uh gun legislation passed at the
federal level but the fundamental
difficulty aside from the Constitutional
issue which is you know it should not be
dismissed uh you have when you pass the
law you have to you have to be sure that
it's going to pass constant
constitutional muster
um the fundamental difficulty is that
there are already so many uh guns in
circulation right if you have you know
400 million or so guns
already owned by Americans there's not
much that you can practically accomplish
with or without the Second Amendment
um you can fiddle at the margins and you
can say well these guns look scary to me
so I'm going to ban them or we think
that if we make the supply of you know
magazines that hold more than 10 rounds
a little bit smaller that that might
reduce fatalities during mass shootings
you know and ignore the possibility that
that restriction might also hurt people
who are using guns for self-defense you
can try to do things like that it may
may not fly in the courts but it does
not have a dramatic impact either on uh
it doesn't have dramatic impact on on
you know the criminals access to the
guns that they need to commit crimes and
there of course you know if you're
criminal you're highly motivated to get
guns and there are plenty of them
already available so there's really not
much legislators can do about that I
think a lot of Americans misunderstand
sort of the reality of of criminal gun
violence in this country uh you know
it's it's not this idea of like oh you
know if more law-abiding Peaceable
citizens have guns the guns will whisper
mean things to them and they will commit
crimes or or kill themselves you know
overwhelmingly overwhelmingly uh that
the gun by violence problem is one of of
what I'll call urban violence it's very
concentrated not just you know within
specific cities but within specific
blocks and neighborhoods of specific
cities and it's overwhelmingly driven by
a very very small subset of repeat
offenders who largely are already
prohibited from Legally purchasing or
possessing firearms who nonetheless
obtain them
um and I think people sort of have this
idea of of you know oh well more guns
that that means more people are just
going to lose their minds on the subway
or you know engage in road rage and
that's really not what's driving most
crime you know as Jacob alluded to it's
it's largely criminals who already have
a plethora of means you know to continue
evading existing gun laws and a lot of
the gun laws that are proposed are not
in any way shape or form directed at
prohibiting them in the channels that
they already use to obtain those guns
um despite their illegality it just
makes it doubly in triply illegal but it
doesn't practically intervene yeah and
this I'm showing a chart here from uh
Carpe Diem a Blog that is uh published
by AEI this data is 10 years out of date
but the the trend line is basically the
same that and this is what convinced me
from a kind of empirical or pragmatic
level uh that not to worry so much about
the increase in the number of guns uh
circulating because they've gone up
tremendously but the uh gun violence
rate uh not just of homicides but just
gun violence in general has has actually
declined from Peak seen in the in the
70s but Amy let me ask you about you
know so uh here's you know here is uh
um this is a Washington Post wonk blog
uh snapshot a pie chart about
um uh ownership of firearm by
perpetrator in Pittsburgh in 2008 again
it's kind of old data but I think these
percentages roughly uh hold up where you
know overwhelmingly the people who
commit crimes with guns are you know
they're not legal owners so what do you
do to you know to clamp down on you know
criminals who are using guns in criminal
ways in a way that does not you know uh
spill over onto the constitutional
rights of legal gun owners yeah so we'll
say there has been some updated uh in
National Data on this I in recent years
and and it roughly correlates with that
yeah
um you know most most people who are in
prison right now for committing violent
crimes with Firearms did not you know
show up at a gun store and buy it that
day right um and it's not just most
people it's like you know 85 90 90 plus
percent right I think there's something
like under one in ten legally bought
that gun like at a brick and mortar gun
store in their their own name um you
know most are getting it through sort of
um
nebulous uh informal markets whether you
know they they quote borrowed it from a
friend or or stole it or just black
market generally however you want to
Define that
um now now what does that mean right so
there are two ways to sort of look at
this one is from the offender standpoint
the other is from the access to firearm
standpoint right so you you know that in
any given City and this is I mean take
take your pick
um you know any city that has looked at
their their gun violence and their gun
homicide problem has come to the same
conclusion that it's overwhelmingly
something like a fraction of a percent
often just like a couple hundred uh core
repeat offenders who are responsible for
either participating in or otherwise
facilitating the majority of gun
violence in that City like they it's
sort of like seven degrees of of
Separation right like it all comes back
to to them
um so you can focus on
um it you know whether it's going after
them criminally or going after them
through other sort of intervention means
uh things like like project ceasefire in
Boston have had great effect what is
projects so projects cease fire and and
it's variations of that
um are essentially targeted
interventions if you will or police and
and local leaders looked at this data
like wow most gun violence is
facilitated by these core individuals
and they focus on deterrence and
prevention and intervention in those
specific high-risk individuals now
sometimes it's sort of strong arming
them I think the original project
ceasefire they they called in gang
leaders because this was the the 90s and
so it was like your traditional
hierarchical gangs
um now it tends to be more interpersonal
disputes like sort of loosely Affiliated
groups of people brought them in and
said stop it you know like like if you
so much as think about getting a gun and
retaliating against people you're going
to jail for the rest of your life you
know the end where they sort of took a
Hardball approach
um but there are various means of doing
that right so not all of it is
criminalization you know sometimes it's
it's focusing
um intervention and sort of like at risk
but it's it's it's good policing that's
targeted to the actual perpetrators and
high-risk areas Jacob can I to uh kind
of uh go along as we're coming to the
close of our time here together let me
uh call this up you know one of the
things uh yeah how many how many deaths
by firearm are there a year
roughly total
uh
I think the total was uh something like
uh 40 something thousand okay is that
right Amy Amy about forty thousand yeah
depending on the erupt roughly 30 to 40
. so and in
your more than half of those are
typically suicides so is that is that a
a concern for public policy that can be
addressed uh in in a meaningful way
again one that you know respects the
Second Amendment rights of you know of
legal lawful people uh but also you know
if 20 000 people a year are committing
suicide by gun
um and that accounts for more than half
of all deaths by guns like is there a
way to deal with that or is that a cost
on society that we say well
um you know that's a uh that's that's a
kind of cost of being a free Society
well I mean the first thing you should
note is that these are very different
problems right they tend to get lumped
together as all gun deaths but when most
of them are suicide
um uh you know whatever policies you
come up for trying to stop uh gun
homicides even assuming they're
effective are not going to be applicable
uh to suicides unless you go for you
know just trying to reduce the General
Supply which which fails for for all the
reasons we've been talking about
um they you know when you talk about red
flag laws the data from the few states
that I've seen uh release data on this
indicate that most of these red flag
orders which say you know you're not
allowed to own a gun for a certain
period of time or because either a
policeman or a family member it depends
on the way the law is written or a
medical professional says this person is
a risk themselves or the public right so
we're suspending the right yeah right so
it's to themselves or others but
typically it's to themselves right um so
that I think people may not realize that
they assume well this is all about
preventing mass shootings but actually
it seems to be mostly about trying to
prevent suicides now if you if you look
at the research on this there isn't much
uh but uh a couple of Studies have
suggested that these programs might have
an impact on suicides but what they
indicate uh is just taking these
estimates at face value and there's some
controversy over them is that uh in the
vast majority of cases the people who
lose their gun rights actually were not
going to kill themselves
um that if you look at the estimate of
the number of suicides that prevented
it's a small fraction of the people who
lost their gun rights so that you know
poses a question of like how many uh how
many cases you're gonna are you willing
to tolerate if people who lose the right
to arm self-defense really for no good
reason in order to try to stop the few
of them actually would have killed
himself from doing that and of course
you know there's also the broader
question of what role does the
government have in trying to prevent
self-harm trying to prevent suicide you
know which we we don't have time to get
into but even assuming that it does have
such a role this does not look like a
very uh well-targeted method uh for
trying to prevent suicide right
um Amy uh talk a little bit about how
that affects things like school
shootings in particular you know school
shootings have a particular purchase on
the public imagination because you know
I it's not as if you know the people who
were attending a country music concert
in Vegas deserve to be shot to death by
some insane person you know in a hotel
room but you know kids are so innocent
Etc is there a way to you know what it
what is the best way to minimize school
shootings which are rare
um you know or statistically basically
zero when you factor in you know the
number of kids in school the number of
schools in the number of school days Etc
but you know it matters and it is
undeniably tragic what are the ways to
address things like school shootings in
a way that will actually help and won't
and will also persuade people that the
issue is not at root violence guns in
circulation
yeah you know again I feel like so much
of this this program has been us talking
about misconceptions that the general
public has and this is this is a huge
one
um our schools at least in terms of of
fatal and and you know sort of lethal
ends violence uh occurring in schools
during school hours at least with
respect to that our schools are actually
incredibly safe kids are are far more
likely to die in a car accident tour
from school than they are any anywhere
else in their day than school yeah and
and most of these school shootings are
not Parkland style events um the ones
that do occur overwhelmingly a good
number of suicides but also like
interpersonal disputes where you know a
kid brought a gun to school because he
was being bullied or because you know
he's he's in a dispute over a girl with
another student
um it's those sorts of of shootings
um so that tells us a couple of things
with respect to these Parkland style
events which again we all agree are
tragic have devastating effects
they're they're also incredibly rare
just as as are all mass shootings
overwhingly with School shooters in
particular these are kids who
well let's put it this way it was not in
an instance where no one saw this coming
right overwhelmingly these are troubled
individuals who have whether or not a
specific mental you know diagnosable
mental illness they have mental health
needs that are overwhelmingly not being
met
um now from a broader context you know
you can say oh well do do we do we try
to treat this very rare specific issue
or do we take a step back as we showed
with with suicides generally
um to tie this back in right only half
of suicides in the United States are
with guns right so if you if you
attacked us as a gun specific problem
you're missing much larger aspects of
the overall problem of mental health so
when you attack it from a general mental
health standpoint
um instead of a gun specific standpoint
you're not only capturing those rare but
very tragic events or those suicides
that are committed with guns right
you're now capturing the the much
broader reality of the violence that is
occurring
um you know you're capturing things when
you focus on on school mental health and
you know providing those services and
ensuring that the kids who are going
through suicidal or depressive moments
um receive that help you're actually
treating the underlying issue because as
we've noted right if you take a with red
flag laws like if you take someone who
is actually suicidal and just remove a
firearm but don't give them help and
don't deal with other lethal means but
you still have a dangerous person and so
I think that's where you need to start
is with that underlying issue because
that's going to impact far far more than
just these rare incidents Jacob could
you also talk about you know when you
think of school shootings like a ball
day or or
um uh the one in Florida the I mean if
if there's a failure here it's really
not a gun control it's the the
perpetrators had multiple you know
interactions with school officials with
mental health officials police were on
site and did nothing
um you know is it is it legitimate to
talk about school shootings not as a
failure of gun control really but of a
larger set of you know kind of
governments
um you know kind of systems of control
that just completely fail to protect the
people they're supposed to be protected
in particular cases I think it's true
there are obvious failures uh by law
enforcement in some cases by school
Personnel
um
Vivaldi was full of mistakes like that
right yeah I mean there were basic
security precautions that are not a
matter of you know turning the school
into a prison or an armed camp or
whatever uh but just basic precautions
that were not taken and the police
response of course was was disastrous
um so and in the case of the um
uh the the Florida shooting
uh they're like you said this this the
the perpetrator had a long history of
run-ins or incidents that indicated that
at the very least he was very troubled
might be the sort of person who could
commit a crime like this but I would
caution it's very easy to look back and
you know in retrospect and say these are
obvious red flags some cases are more
obvious than others but
the vast majority of teenagers in this
case who who show signs like these will
not commit a crime like this right
almost none of them will so I'm a little
bit concerned about
rushing to identify troubled teenagers
as potential Mass shooters
um and and with all the stigma that
comes from that
um uh in based on the premise that we're
going to you know be able to predict who
actually will come back because
generally speaking we can't do that uh
so so and is there any reason to believe
that you know teenagers today or
adolescents are more violent
or more pathological than they were when
you and I were teenagers Jacob well I
mean just judging from General crime
rates no I mean I mean if anything
they're left yeah right
um yeah I mean there's obvious there
there are there's a real problem here as
Amy said in not helping people who need
help
but I don't think it should all be
framed around
um you know let's stop the next Mass
shooter yeah uh because probably you're
not that's not what you're doing you
know it's it's fine to say that you know
this kid needs support or needs help or
you just talk to somebody simply because
you know we're worried about it whether
whether we're worried that he's going to
hurt himself or hurt other people
um uh is you know it's still a situation
where um he needs help yeah and honestly
like most of these Mass Shooters uh
specifically School related Mass
Shooters um you know you take the the
kid in Parkland for example right they
are a danger to themselves right far far
before they're a danger to others or at
least you know in tandem with it you
know you've got a kid there who
literally called 9-1-1 saying I'm I'm in
crisis my mom died I'm I'm hurting
myself I don't know how to handle this
someone please help me and nothing gets
done right um so I I think that is
objectively correct that everyone is
better off when you take it out of this
specific framing of always you know
we're trying to stop the next school
shooting and and and frame it as like
you have a lot of kids in Mental Health
crisis you need help some some of whom
might plausibly become a school shooter
but if you take that step back and deal
with the underlying issues you're also
then setting yourself up to to deal with
those few issues that become school
shooting related
um if if we may uh as we uh come to the
close of this Amy I wanted to talk with
you about the database that you maintain
at the Heritage Foundation for defensive
gun uses in the United States can you
explain you know that is that's a uh
part of the conversation about gun you
know gun ownership in America that
typically doesn't get discussed very
much at all but what what are you trying
to accomplish by you know creating a
database so that it's constantly updated
about defensive gun use in the United
States and what are the findings of your
uh research yeah well so this is a huge
aspect not just of the gun conversation
you know is a policy
perspective but but from the standpoint
of what is the point of the Second
Amendment you know it's it's about
ensuring that that people have an actual
effective means to enforce their
inalienable right to self-defense
whether that's individually against
Crime or collectively against tyranny or
foreign Invasion um so so self-defense
is at the heart of the Second Amendment
and so this started as an effort
to to really
combat and push back against the The
Narrative you know you have those
interactive maps of you know school
shootings and uh you know all of the
things that are wrong
um but defensive gun used to sort of fly
under the radar and on on the one hand
we knew that we would only be kept
catching a a fraction of all of these
when you look at the actual numbers on
defensive gun use uh you're looking at
between 500 000 to 3 million defensive
gun uses a year in the United States now
that's not my number that is actually a
direct quote from a CDC report yes that
CDC the anti-gun CDC
um from from 2013 they looked at all of
the available studies on this issue and
that's what they found with with very
few exceptions it's somewhere between
500 000 and 3 million
um
yeah I was going to say that tells us I
mean that range seems it means that the
data is probably kind of shady take it
right it is because it's hard to study
um but I I'll say this
um even the two outlier studies still
found about 60 000 to 90
000 which is nothing to shake a stick
out right so we don't know the exact
number
um because it's it's much harder to
quantify you know most people who have a
defensive gun use there's there's good
reason to believe they don't have to
fire that weapon so they're not exactly
showing up to report that I'd be like
hello 9-1-1 I pointed a gun at a guy
right most of the ones that we find and
you'll see this in the defensive gun use
database they're what I'll call major
defensive gun uses things where a a gun
is right you know it's hard to hide a
dead body right that gets reported law
enforcement it uh gets a write-up in the
media but what we were finding is that
even with these major ones
um you know these these thousands of of
ones that that happen every every single
year if you blink on the Nightly News or
if you don't watch the Nightly News or
you know you don't physically have your
local paper with your uh you know one
paragraph write up about the home
Intruder you probably don't realize how
often this is happening everywhere near
you and so we created this interactive
database we put on their point blankets
it's the tip of the iceberg but here's
the ones that you've missed and I think
it gives a really good
um way for for people to see one what's
happening near them and two to to see to
essentially give a context a face a name
um you know a a a big a more specific
picture that these are not Vigilantes
who are out there uh you know trying to
to find criminals these are people who
are just living their lives they're
being everyday ordinary Americans and
crime happened to them and but for their
second amendment rights they might be
dead injured or their livelihoods
destroyed
um so that's what we are trying to do
here
um and again it's regularly updated just
the tip of the iceberg um but these are
all the media verified it's really
fascinating and it builds on you know
previous work done by people like Gary
cleck and other uh you know uh Scholars
and researchers of this and it and it
seems to me like if anybody is trying to
be a good faith you know a discussant or
analysis analyst of gun rights like
you've got to look at costs and benefits
and this is certainly uh you know one of
the benefits Jacob uh real uh quickly
and I I want to ask you very quickly
about the NRA and then I want to ask
each of you a final question about
common sense gun control but first can
you you know and I I started a reason in
1993 and whenever you know if guns came
up people were always talking about the
NRA the National Rifle Association which
you have been critical over the you know
the course of your career as a you know
as an effective and principle to
advocate for gun rights in general
um but like where is the NRA right now
because that's an organization that has
really kind of Hit the hit the
hasn't it
well in terms of their internal scandals
yes uh but uh I mean they were a major
major player in politics and you know
local state and federal politics I mean
even even before all the revelations of
what you know members money was used for
um there were problems with the way the
NRA defended the Second Amendment uh I.E
they did not do it consistently I mean I
mentioned all of these prohibitions for
broad categories Americans with no
History of Violence who are have been
permanently deprived of their second
amendment rights so that really does not
talk about that and in fact they talk
about enforcing those laws and how we
need to go after the bad guys meaning
including all of these people who are
are uh what what they call prohibited
persons right and so that that includes
millions of Americans who are peaceful
and not threatening to others but who
don't have the right to arm self-defense
that seems to to me to be a huge issue
but it's not one the NRA is interested
in pursuing you know to the contrary
um and uh you know they also do not pay
attention
to the way that drug laws intersect with
gun with gun laws that uh uh first of
all that we have the broad prohibitions
that are based both on illegal drug use
and on convictions for drug crimes
which don't make sense in terms of
Public Safety and secondly you have drug
crimes that are punished more severely
when people happen to have firearms
um I mean there was a case uh that I
that I wrote about recently and reason
that it happened several years ago where
I got a 55-year sentence he was a pretty
small time marijuana dealer he had three
transactions within with a police
informant where he sold I think eight
ounces each time made maybe a thousand
dollars in Revenue right
um and he had no prior record he got 55
years because of this gun law that says
if you uh use a gun in furtherance of a
drug trafficking crime we're going to
impose these very severe mandatory
minimum penalties uh that's insane and
it's blatantly unjust uh Weldon Angelus
is the name of the guy he yelled at
where I got released uh because not
because he got clemency but because the
prosecutors finally decided to they're
willing you know to stop challenging his
but that was the kind of thought that
the NRA was pushing all along well yeah
because they they the way they say it is
that we're going after the bad guys
criminals including drug dealers right
so it would include somebody like Wells
and Angelos who's not a public menace by
any means
um and they sort of sweep everybody
um who uh you know violates the drug
laws into that category of dangerous
criminals the people we need to go after
um so they've never been good at that
um and uh you know the idea I mean their
positions are inconsistent because they
will they are willing to criticize
existing gun laws and say this is not
right it's not right that a woman who is
licensed to carry a gun in Pennsylvania
and doesn't realize that means she
doesn't mean she's allowed to drive
through New Jersey with her gun so you
get arrested can go to prison for
several years that's not right it is not
right they're right about that right but
they don't say you know what about
somebody who's disqualified from owning
a gun for arbitrary reasons yeah it gets
arrested and can go to prison for up to
15 years that's not right either
um so uh I think that's a that's always
been a problem with their message
regardless of their current political
influence or their current internal
problems okay
um so a final question for you each Amy
you are obviously a strong advocate for
second amendment rights for gun
ownership independent of constitutional
you know uh history and and legislation
and stuff like that is there such a
thing as Common Sense gun control
because this is one of the things that
you hear in the rhetoric or is it you
know should people be allowed to own
whatever weapons they want whenever they
want and carry them wherever they want
and the reason I raise this is again as
somebody who is generally you know very
favorable towards as robust the Second
Amendment right as possible you know I
hear people say somebody like Ronald
Reagan in today's GOP or in today's gun
control debate would be to the left of
Joe Biden or something like that but you
know is are what are what are legitimate
kind of abridgements or restrictions on
gun ownership that you think you know
should be in place if any yeah look so I
I think on
on the one hand you can make an argument
about like who are the people to whom
the right belongs but I think outside of
that I I think most people are going to
agree right people actively in prison or
mental health institutions or who are
actively a danger to themselves or
others should not have firearms for as
long as they are actively dangerous uh
you know things of that nature that are
very clearly in the interest of of the
public safety
um you know I don't think that you know
your mentally ill uncle has a god-given
right to drive an armor-plated Hummer
down the streets of New York City
whenever he wants with a 50 caliber
machine gun on top right and I think
some of that is textual you know when
does something like a Howitzer become
ordinance or a bearable arms right I
think there is discussion there with
legitimate textual concerns but I think
realistically most gun control as we
think of it today is is less Common
Sense than actually like a Grassroots
taking on the mantle of responsible gun
ownership and I'll give you just one
example right so um you know we talked
about ways to sort of combat the black
market of firearms right well one of one
of the most common ways that that
Firearms end up on the black market is
that guns are stolen
um you know we don't have good numbers
but thousands if not tens of thousands
and hundreds of thousands of guns are
stolen every year
um it's a huge problem now you can say
we're going to have gun control we're
gonna have this government top-down
approach where we are going to mandate
that your gun has to be locked up and
unloaded I mean you have to spend
hundreds of dollars uh on a safe and you
can't have it on your person
um that sort of thing
but we can enforce it because we're not
going to send government you know door
to door to do it and we're going to
price certain people out of their
inalienable right
or we can incentivize gun owners
um either by removing laws that have
them keeping their guns in their car
because they can't carry it on their
person or by educating them on like we
know you don't want your guns stolen
either that's very expensive here's the
best way of doing it I think that
Grassroots ground up approach is far
more common sense and far more efficient
and effective in so many cases than
anything we consider like government
top-down Common Sense gun control
Jacob uh what about you is there you
know uh as a and I'm forgetting when it
was but Peter bagg uh wrote a uh you
know reasons kind of In-House cartoonist
uh I think wrote an essay about a
cartoon essay about this but on the
cover it was like the right to own a
bazooka do you know do individual
Americans have a right to own a bazooka
and if not why not
I mean Another Second Amendment the
question is you know what are bearable
arms because it's the right to keep in
bear arms right so it's not nuclear
missiles
um it's not not things that that are
impractical to carry on your person to
use for self-defense
um in terms of people
I think it is legitimate to say look
here is uh an armed robber
uh uh he was convicted of armed robbery
he used a gun
we think maybe it's not such a good idea
for him to have guns in the future and
we're going to say either as part of the
sentence or part of the more narrowly
tailored law
he's not allowed to
have guns
if somebody gets into a bar brawl All Is
convicted of uh uh
felony assault
and first late after he is you know much
more stable
I'm just
responsible
oh
and law abiding is still not allowed to
have a gun for self-defense I think
there's something
all right uh you know what uh I think
we're experiencing a little bit of
technical difficulty but uh Jacob got
his uh last comments and I want to thank
Jacob Sullivan my reason senior editor
colleague uh his bio is in the show
notes Here look read through everything
that he's written about the Second
Amendment on gun rights and gun culture
I also want to thank Amy swear of the
Heritage Foundation uh Amy thanks so
much and uh you are gun defensive gun
use database and the list uh your book
uh the essential second amendments also
in the show notes here please check them
out Amy thanks so much for joining us
thank you so much for having me and
Jacob if you're there uh thank you all
right very good uh and uh come back next
Thursday what I'll be uh rejoined by my
regular co-host Zack weismuller and
we'll be talking to other people of
interest and relevance to uh to your
life uh your politics and your culture
thanks everyone everybody
thank you thanks